>> Speaker 1: From the Library
of Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Michael North: Hello
everyone and welcome
to the Lessing J. Rosenwald
Room in the Rare Book
and Special Collections Division
of the Library of Congress.
Thank you for coming to
this month's Thursday
Afternoon Lecture.
My name is Michael
North and I'm head
of the Rare Book Reading room,
which is right across the hall.
Today I am pleased to
introduce Elise Friedland,
who is Associate Professor
of Classics and Art History
in the Department of Classical
and Near Eastern Languages
and Civilizations at the George
Washington University here
in Washington D.C. She
holds a B.A. in Classics
from Williams College and a
M.A. and Ph.D. in Classical Art
and Archeology from
the University
of Michigan in Ann Arbor.
Professor Friedland specializes
in Roman Marble Sculpture
that was imported and displayed
in the Ancient Near East
and she has published two
co-edited volumes on the topic,
The Sculptural Environment
of the Roman Near East:
Reflections on Culture,
Ideology, and Power in 2008
and the Oxford Handbook
of Roman Sculpture in 2015
by Oxford University Press
as well as a monograph,
The The Roman Marble Sculptures
From the Sanctuary of Pan
at Caesarea, Philippi/Panias
in Israel in 2012.
Her current research, which
investigates American adoptions
and adaptations of
classical motifs grows
out of a course she developed
for George Washington University
entitled Greece and Rome
in Washington D.C.:
Classical Influences
on our Founding Fathers.
In the fall of 2017 Professor
Friedland was granted a U.S.
Capitol Historical
Society Fellowship
to study Constantino Brumidi
Pompeiian style 19th century
fresco cycle in the Senate
Appropriations Committee Room,
S127, in the Senate wing of
the U.S. Capitol Building.
Please welcome her.
[ Applause ]
>> Elise Friedland: Thank
you so much, Michael,
and thank you for
this opportunity.
Thank you all for coming.
I'm delighted to be here and
Michael did a pretty good job
of giving you some background
but I just needed to go
through some thank yous
before we get started.
So, a lot of people have been
very wonderful and gracious
and supportive and, first,
I have to thank the team
from the Office of the
Curator of the Capitol.
So we have a curator of the
Capitol here, Michele Cohen,
and some assistant
Curators of the Capitol,
Jen Blancato and Vickie Villano.
And I also want to
thank the former Curator
of Capitol, Barbara Wolanin.
As Michael said, I had a had a
U.S. Capitol Historical Society
fellowship and I'd also like to
thank William diGiacomantonio
for that and all his
support and also a colleague
at George Mason University,
Carol Mattusch.
My own institution also supplied
some funding for this so got
to give GW a little shout out.
But also, there was an
entire team from the Library
of Congress who has been
incredible in helping me
on my magical adventure that
I've been on since last August.
So starting with
Michael North here,
who retrieved these giant books
from Fort Meade on my behalf,
and then Stephanie Stillo and
Jeff Flannery, Barbara Natanson
in prints and photographs,
Cheryl Fox the archivist here,
Michelle Krowl, who you'll see
helped me with Megs journal,
John Cole, the historian,
and Jan McElvey.
So it's been a fabulous
experience conducting research
here but it's taken quite
a lineup of specialists
and experts to support me
and I'm incredibly
thankful to everyone.
As Michael said, I don't usually
deal with books, rare books,
because we don't have any
more of those from when I work
and where I usually live.
I usually live in
the Roman world
because I'm a Roman sculpture
specialist and, in particular,
I work in the Ancient Near
East, in Israel and Jordan.
So you can just see
what I'm doing there.
So your question is probably
what are you doing talking
about 19th century painting
and 19th century publications.
Well, as Michael
pointed out, when I moved
to GW exactly ten years ago, I
developed a course called Greece
and Rome in Washington
D.C.: Classical Influences
on Our Founding Fathers.
And as part of that class
I called up the curator
of the Capitol and asked if
she would give my class a tour
and that was Barbara Wolanin.
And she took us all
around the Capitol
and showed us architecture
but she also showed
us some painting.
This famous fresco on the
underside of the Rotunda
by Constantino Brumidi, right?
The Apotheosis of
George Washington.
And then she took
us into another,
she took us into the Senate
corridors and this room, S127.
And we were there for
about ten minutes.
And when we came out
I said to her, "Whoa.
There's a lot going
on in that room."
And she said, "Yes!
And no one has ever studied
it before completely.
Would you like to do that?"
And I thought to myself, dude,
that is after Constantine.
My world ends in 324
A.D. I am not responsible
for anything after Constantine.
And besides, that's
painting, I do sculpture.
So in my head I had this whole
dialogue and I said, "Oh,
that's an interesting thought."
And then I moved on.
Three years later I'm
teaching the class again,
I try to email Barbara to
get a tour, no response.
I call the office, Vickie
answers and says, "Oh,
I'm sure the new Curator
of the Capitol would
like to give you a tour."
And so then I met Michelle and
she took our class in there
for 45 minutes and while she
was talking to my students
about Brumidi finally got
a look at that room, S127.
It was originally made for
the Naval Affairs Committee
and today is the Senate
Appropriations Committee
Meeting Room.
And we had this fabulous
exchange
about some things I was seeing
in the room and she said,
"You know, I really think you
should work on this room."
She had no idea what Barbara
had said and so then I thought,
okay, that's two Curators
of the Capitol in the space
of three years, somebody is
trying to tell me something.
And the rest is history.
Right? So here is the room
that we are talking about.
This is S127.
Today this is the Senate
Appropriations Committee
Meeting Room.
But originally, as I said,
it was made to house the Naval
Affairs Committee, right,
and it did that from
about 1860 until 1897.
Then it housed a variety
of different committees
until it became the Senate
Appropriations Committee Meeting
Room in 1912.
This room is pretty important
in terms of its decoration
because it is the first
full-scale commission done
by Constantino Brumidi,
right, the guy who was famous
for the Apotheosis right here.
This is actually his first
full-scale commission.
And it is pretty
different than many
of his other painted
rooms in the Senate wing.
Why? Because if you look at
it, for example, in comparison
to the Senate Reception Room,
it is much more coherent,
this Naval Affairs Committee
Meeting room is much more
coherent in terms of
its style so this tends
to mix a variety of
different styles.
It is also much more coherent in
terms of its narrative program,
what is the story it's trying
to tell through the paintings.
So, this is a pretty important
first thing by Brumidi
in the Capitol to study.
And, in fact, I want to give
you a little bit of background
about our artist, Brumidi.
He was actually Italian, right?
so he was born in
Rome and he went
to a very famous
art academy there,
the Academy di San Luca and,
unfortunately, he got caught
up in the Italian
Revolution and sort
of became a political refugee,
such that in 1952 he came
to the United States.
And he was here because
he had commissions
in churches in New York.
He also painted in
Philadelphia, Baltimore,
Havana, and even Mexico City.
And at one point he was on
his way, at one point in 1854,
I think, he was on his way back
from Mexico City to New York,
his sort of home base when
he met Montgomery Meigs,
who had been hired as the
engineer of the Capitol
to complete the construction,
and the believed,
decoration of the
Capitol Building.
And so Meigs, it was perfect
timing because Meigs was looking
for someone who could
decorate the interior
of the Capitol Building with
elaborate, Roman style frescoes
and he was having a dreadful
time finding any American
painter who was able
to fit that bill.
And along came Constantine
Brumidi.
So he, Meigs hired Brumidi
to do a little test panel
on the House side apparently
the Senators were very favorable
about it.
Meigs liked it and
the rest is history.
He hired Constantino Brumidi,
who is today sometimes known
as the Michelangelo
of the Capitol
or the artist of the Capitol.
Now, what I wanted to do is
give you a quick orientation
to the room because then I want
to get to well why are you here
in the Library of Congress,
like what does this got to do,
why shouldn't we be in the
Capitol Building right now.
So let me just sort of give you
a quick visual tour of the room
and then I will explain
what we're doing here.
So this is the room from
another angle and you can see
that the decorative program,
the fresco cycle involves
sort of four main areas.
It involves the walls, right?
So there are nine of these
sort of solid background panels
with floating maidens in them
and then it involves
these lunettes.
I'm actually just go like this.
So there are nine of these kinds
of panels and then the lunettes
over them that, today, have
architectural scenes in them.
They were originally meant
to have famous naval battles
from American history in them.
There are two bays in the room,
actually I'm going to back
up just so you can see that.
Can you see that there's one bay
here and then another bay here?
And on these bays there are sort
of four areas that have niches
in them and each niche is filled
with its own marine deity right?
Because you're in the Naval
Affairs Committee Meeting Room.
So, you know, you can
see there's Neptune
and we have Amphitrite,
and we have Aeolus.
So there's one who is
the Goddess America
so she's a little aberration.
But anyway, and each deity is
in a niche and then flanked
by two attendants, right?
And then finally,
there are these bands,
there are three bands.
One up here, there's one
in the center of the room,
and there's one on the
other side of the room.
So that is Brumidi's
decorative scheme for this room.
Now, it was known to the former
Curator of the Capitol, I mean,
this room obviously looks
very Roman in style, right?
But, in fact, the former Curator
of the Capitol had identified
one part of this room
that seemed to be a dead ringer
for or was definitely based
on an actual painting
from Pompeii.
And so you can see
that right here.
I'm just going to test this
but I know [inaudible].
The pointer doesn't
work on this,
you need a reflective surface.
Anyway, so this is a floating
[inaudible] right here
and if we look she is
actually based on this fresco,
this Roman wall painting,
that is from the House
of the Ship at Pompeii, okay?
And her question was, the reason
she had approached me was she
wanted to know were there
other matches in the room
or did Brumidi sort of
start with this and kind
of make the rest of
the room up, right?
So that was the big
question and that's sort
of why Barbara Wolanin and
Michelle Cohen hired me
to study this room, right?
And I began in August
of 2017 and I kind
of was getting panicked
by early October
because I wasn't
finding any other matches
and I started getting
really nervous that a bunch
of people are going to be
very disappointed in me
and then I realized,
let's think about this.
Naval Affairs Committee
Meeting Room,
this is from the
House of the Ship.
I wonder if Brumidi had some
publication of the House
of the Ship and took a bunch
of other figures from that
and altered them, right?
But then I couldn't find
any publication of the House
of the Ship but I did
find this drawing,
which is in Volume
One right over there.
Okay? And it turns out that this
is the only complete drawing
of the entire wall in which are
floating maenad figures, okay?
It is very common to see just
this floating maenad reproduced
in several publications
from the early 19th century
of wall paintings from Pompeii.
But this is the only complete
drawing of the entire wall,
which was the south wall of
a dining room in this House
of the Ship, the
Casa de Naviglio.
And it turns out
that this drawing is
from the very important
publication by Wilhelm Zahn,
the most beautiful ornaments and
the most fancy wall paintings
from Pompeii [inaudible], okay?
And as I was looking at
this drawing and saying yes,
there's are maenad, I
started realizing, hold on.
I recognize other things
like these columns, right?
So, oops, sorry, so there's
our floating in maenad, right?
You can see, but I also
recognized those columns
and then I realized
that it turns
out that Constantino Brumidi
based his entire design
of the room on this one drawing.
So you can see that he not
only adopts flanking floating
maenads, he turns
them into maidens,
but he's got the
flanking columns
and the secondary scene got
turned into a doorway, right?
So less work for him creating
complex figural scenes.
Not that he couldn't take that
on, he was fabulous, right?
And, in fact, this
scheme, the design scheme
for the walls goes even
further because you can see
that the wall in the
Pompeiian dining room had this
vegetal border.
Well, we have that here,
a version by Brumidi.
It was originally topped by
some fantastic creatures;
they got turned into swans
and it had some vegetal motifs
in the lower corner
and those got turned
into cornucopia by Brumidi.
So he really did look
very carefully at this
and match what he
was doing one to one.
So the question for me was
then okay, I began to read
about this book by
Wilhelm Zahn and I realized
that this was a big, large,
fancy, expensive book.
It is not something that a
political refugee is going
to be carrying from Italy
across the ocean with him.
So I thought, how did
he have access for this
and what is this book.
The other thing that struck
me was that, you know,
I teach a course on Pompeii
and I do a little part of that
on the history of Pompeii
and the transmission
of Pompeiian art, you
know, the dissemination
of the images and things.
And I thought why have I
never heard of Wilhelm Zahn?
I mean, I know William Gell,
I know Francois [inaudible].
I know all these
characters, I'll introduce you
to them in a little bit.
I'd never heard of Wilhelm Zahn.
And I started asking some of my
colleagues, oh, Wilhelm Zahn?
And they'd say, yeah, I've
never really heard of him.
And I thought well that's weird
because Brumidi has
heard of him.
And where is his book because
I also had spoken with somebody
that I got connected to through
the U.S. Capitol Historical
Society, who is a painter
who does historical paintings
of D.C. and I said, "So,
could Brumidi have done
this from his head?"
And he said, "Absolutely not.
He would've needed a
model to design something
that complex, absolutely not."
So I decided to start looking
around where could
I find this book
and I thought did the Library
of Congress own this book.
And that's why we're here today
because I ended up getting
in touch with Michael
North and I said, "Look,
in your catalogue it says
you have these books,
could I see them?"
And he heroically got them from
Fort Meade where they've been
in storage for goodness
knows how long and behold,
I was able to find
tons more matches.
So these columns here that
Brumidi painted in the room,
you can see that this
lower part comes directly
from this drawing
by Zahn, right?
On plate 16 and we're
going to watch
because another part he also
takes from the same place, okay?
So not only does he base
architectural features,
he also has an individual
drawing
of just his favorite
floating maenad
and there are other floating
figures that match as well.
So she was a victory
goddess, carrying a trophy.
So you just, you know, lose
the wings and change the trophy
into a pennant and you've got to
put clothes on all these people
in 19th century America.
And there you have
another floating figure.
Some of the attendants
also come directly
from Wilhelm Zahn's drawings so,
and here we have the
original still today
in the Naval Archeological
Museum,
and you can check this out,
even down to this tongue
sticking out, right,
Brumidi has based
this on this drawing.
Right? Brumidi, we can't
guarantee, would know this
but we can see that he was
looking at Wilhelm Zahn
and just another
attendant flanking Neptune.
You can see here, okay, so
it was Europa and the bull
but he changed the
bull into a hippocamp
and then the horse
turned his head away
because it was this sort of
romantic myth behind [laughter].
So, but you can see, right?
You believe me that Brumidi was
actually using Wilhelm Zahn's
drawings, right?
Okay, so how did Brumidi
get a hold of this book
and the real question is could
these books be the exact copies
that Zahn was using?
And he had the commission
for this room in 1856
and he completed it in 1958.
So the hunt was on.
Here I am when I first
met Michael and the books
by Wilhelm Zahn, right?
And I wanted to try
to figure out whether
or not Brumidi could've
used these.
And this is one of the funniest
stories of this whole mystery.
I mean, I'm an archeologist
and an art historian
and I've worked in museums.
You know, I've been a
visiting assistant curator here
and blah, blah, blah.
So I turned to Michael
when I got a hold
of these books finally
and I said,
"Could I see your
file on these books?"
And he looked at me and he
said, "File on the books?"
And I said, "Well, yeah.
Where have these things been?"
Like, I don't know,
where did you get them,
when did you get them,
who's used them?"
And he said, "We don't
keep files like that."
And I thought, what do you mean?
Because in a museum every object
that walks in the building
and belongs to your collection
has a file and you know
where it's been every second
of every day basically.
And he said, "We have a
lot of books like this."
So I was like, right,
okay, I'm going to have
to reconstruct the
provenience of this book.
So there were several
things that were helpful
like when I began
sleuthing together, right?
It turns out that there is
a blind stamp in the front,
on the frontis page
of both of these books
and that blind stamp
is actually tied
to the first international
copyright law.
This is all very exciting.
Because you can see it says
Vertrag Vom 13 Mai 1846.
So in 1846 on the 13tth
of May there was a convention
established between Prussia
and Britain that had
to do with the export
of books and paying taxes.
And so if a book was meant to
be exported to Britain it had
to have this kind of stamp on
it and so we know, therefore,
that the book, which
incidentally was printed
in Berlin by a very famous
publisher, Gaylord [inaudible]
and the Volume One
was printed in 1829,
Volume Two that you
see there 1841 to 44,
Volume Three we don't have
because it was after Brumidi
and he didn't use it, but
that was 1852 to 1859.
So we know that the same
Volume One, at least,
was printed in 1829 and it had
to have left Germany [inaudible]
term after September 1st,
when this went into
effect, of 1846.
Okay, that's good, right?
So we kind of have an idea
of when the book left.
We know that it must've gone
to Britain otherwise it wouldn't
have had that stamp in it.
But Michael said, yeah,
not to worry there are tons
of book sellers, right,
selling to America in Britain
so that's cool, that
could've taken that path.
There's also this stamp on
this book stamp of the Library
of Congress and it turns
out that this was a common stamp
used in the mid 19th century
and actually the
archivist, Cheryl,
told me one of the dead
ringers here said this is listed
as Library of Congress
City of Washington,
as opposed to Washington
D.C., that the name tends
to change after the Civil War.
Okay? So that was good but
here is the dead ringer.
Then I began searching
through published catalogues
of the Library of Congress to
try to determine if I could see
when we acquired
this book, right?
And that also required
Michael's help
because although the HathiTrust
has a lot of the catalogues,
the published catalogues of
the Library of Congress online.
They didn't have
anything between 1830
and like 1850-something
and so, after my time,
like 1859 or something.
I was like, "I have this gap,
Michael do you have your
catalogue from 18," you know.
And so I looked through all
the catalogues and, behold,
we can see that in 1849, here's
the first record of the Library
of Congress's ownership
of Zahn's publication.
And we have Volumes
One and Two here,
note that they're classified
under gardening, painting,
et cetera, according
to Jefferson's category
of imagination [inaudible].
I thought that was very
funny [inaudible], et cetera.
But there they are.
So we know that they made their
way here by 1849 and that's
in plenty of time for our
hero to consult them in 1854
or 56, so that's exciting.
So that's good.
So I think I can make
a pretty sound argument
that he could've used
these exact volumes.
But then I decided to
try going a step further.
So it turns out that
Montgomery Meigs, who was kind
of Brumidi's patron if
you will, kept a journal.
Fortunately, I mean,
and he wrote
down every matter of detail.
It was unbelievable.
Well, it's only unbelievable
if you read
if in the transcribed
version because it turns
out that the guy wrote in this
thing called Pittman shorthand.
[inaudible] anyone ever tried
to read Pittman shorthand?
So, okay, my daughter is taking
Arabic and you saw that some
of my research is in Jordan.
It's like scarier than Arabic.
Here, look [laughter].
Even more impenetrable
to me than Arabic.
So I went over to Madison
and I met with Jeff Flannery
and he got the journal out
for me and we tried to look
at it because, see, what
happened was in 2000
for the anniversary of
the Capitol Building,
they hired this incredible
person
who could still read
Pittman shorthand
to transcribe the diaries
of Montgomery Meigs,
especially the ones
that had to do
with the Capitol
Building, right?
So I had this searchable
pdf and I could see,
in English you know
[laughter], that I could see
that on June 22nd, 1858,
when my room is completed,
Brumidi is all done
with the room,
Meigs is in there admiring
a room and he says,
"The Pompeiian rooms are better
than the examples from Pompeii
in the book of blank
and the other styles are
as well represented as in
any of the plates given
in any of these books."
Well, what happened was our
transcriber was going along
doing his thing transcribing
but he doesn't know names
like [inaudible], Gell,
Zahn, Niccolini, [inaudible],
he doesn't know those names.
So he came across a word
that was a proper name
that he didn't know
and he left it blank.
And there are blanks like this
throughout the transcription.
You can understand, right?
It's hard to keep up
with Montgomery Meigs.
So Jeff and I thought maybe
we could look at the diary
and we could figure this out.
And then we looked at the
diary and we were like, yeah,
you pretty much need to
read Pittman shorthand
to figure that out.
So then I met Michelle
Krowl and she said, "Well,
I have an elderly woman who
used to do some things for us
who lives in Quincy,
Massachusetts.
Here's her email address."
So I emailed her
and she was amazing.
She emailed me back.
I sent her color
printouts of these images
with stickies everywhere
and I could tell that this,
because it's the last sentence
of the June 22nd journal entry
and this is the last sentence
because there's an x here
that means the end of the
sentence and here's 23rd
for the start of the next
journal entry, right?
So I could see there's the
end of the previous sentence.
So I knew it was this sentence
and I could kind of see
that some of the words
were being repeated,
Pompeii or Pompeiian.
So I was able to narrow it
down and she read it for me
and she said, "Hey, guess what?
There's your word and it says,"
it's like phonetic
shorthand, so it says, "Zahn."
So in case you were doubting
[laughter] my art historical
sleuthing and all the other
words that everyone else
at the Library of Congress
had been doing to help me,
Montgomery Meigs went
and confirmed it for us.
Should've just read
the journal, well.
In any event, so that
pretty much tells us
that these volumes, you know,
there was the slight question,
did they make it
through the fire in 1851?
But I've sort of
left that alone.
I chose not to go
down that rabbit hole.
This is filled with
rabbit holes.
So anyway, I don't know,
I believe that I can make
a fairly strong argument
for the fact that our hero
was, and Meigs as patron,
were looking at these
exact volumes.
So, then my question
was well how did we know
to buy those things in 1849?
Because I don't know about them
and I'm a scholar of, you know,
Roman art and I teach
a course on Pompeii
and I've never heard
of this dude.
So how do they know to buy these
volumes by Wilhelm Zahn, right?
And so what I thought I should
do is put this in a little bit
of a context of the history
of excavations of Pompeii.
So here's a map of Pompeii and
I don't know if you can sort
of read this from where you're
sitting but it has the dates
of all the excavations
of the city.
And you can see that we are
sort of, we're, so the House
of the Ship is discovered
in 1826
and that's this blue
part, right?
And Brumidi is alive
and sort of learning
to be an artist during the
largest excavation campaign
to date, which occurred
between 1850 and 1860, right?
I mean, Pompeii gets
discovered in 1748,
initially they thought it was
actually another little town,
[inaudible].
So it took them a while to
figure out where they were
and these first excavations,
which you can see here,
it's a light grey but it doesn't
show up very well on the screen,
were in this theater
area triangular forum
and a little piece up here but
then there was a second wave
of excavations in 1806 to
1815, so-called French decade.
But then the Bourbon
Restoration from 1850 to 1860 is
when there's really the
largest scale excavations
that had ever been
conducted at the site.
And this is the lifetime
of Brumidi, right?
And the other thing that's
important for you to know,
just here's a little marker
to show you where that House
of the Ship is located, right?
So it was excavated in three
different years and our room
with its wall painting
is found in 1826.
So this means that this is also
the era of huge publication
of the site of Pompeii.
And this is the time when all
sorts of, you know, artists
and architects and elites were
going to the Bay of Naples area
and looking at the discoveries
that were being made
before their very eyes
at Pompeii, right?
So this is the, you know, still
the era of the grand tour.
I don't know if you've
heard of the grand tour.
And so here are some examples
of the kinds of publications
that were beginning
to appear, right?
And it's just three
of the most important
and well known publications
from the first half
of the 19th century.
So we have William Gell,
who writes something called
Pompeiana and it's published
between 1817 and 1832.
French, Francois Mazois
[inaudible] Pompeii from 1824
to 1838, and then the
famous Niccolini brothers,
Fausto and Felice
Niccolini in 1854.
And what I wanted you to see was
that these volumes are
very similar to one another
because while they do have some
plates in them and some drawings
and some of them are these
very alluring reconstructions
that get populated by
ancients, you know.
So you can, they sort of
reconstruct the houses
that have been excavated and
they install Romans in them,
you know, swishing around
the atrium or whatever.
Most of what's in
these volumes is
that [laughter] narrative
discussion
of what they are discovering.
Very helpful, extremely
important but as I began
to dabble in 19th century
publications from the University
of Heidelberg and the
Getty Research Institute,
thank God for digitization
of these things,
and then I was looking at these,
I thought Zahn doesn't
look like these guys.
He's different, right?
And in fact, Zahn is
different in a lot of ways
and so here's just the frontis
from Volume One that you can see
on the screen and we could
look at later if you wanted.
So how is Zahn different?
First of all, Zahn
is bilingual, right?
So those others that I
had shown you, you know,
one was by a British guy,
one was by a French guy,
the Niccolini brothers
are Italian,
and they're in their
respective languages, right?
We are bilingual, we're
in German and in French
and the real difference is these
are really virtually all images.
He has one page of "texts" that
are mini catalogue entries.
So you have some minimal
information about the background
for each image, that
appears at the front,
and then there are a
bunch of plates in between
and then there's
another set of 10
and a bunch of plates
in between.
So there's only one
page of text per folio.
It is not at all a narrative
in any way, shape, or form.
And the other thing
that's radically different
about these is the color.
Okay? And you can see that
as you look at the table
and you can see that here.
And it really makes Zahn,
oops, where's my color?
There you go, it really
makes Zahn stand out, right?
So who was this guy and, you
know, I figured I'm going
to have to put this guy
on the map a little bit
for the general discussion.
Certainly, specialists who
work with this era know
about him but, you know,
people who are just general
Roman art historians seem
to not have heard of him.
So he was a German
decorative painter.
He was born in 1800 and he
trained at the Casell Academy
of Fine Arts, after which he
went to Paris for about a year
and hung out with Antione
[inaudible] very famous
neoclassical painter.
And then Wilhelm Zahn lived in
Pompeii from 1824 or 25 to 1829
and again from 1830 to 1840.
And he was just hanging
around while things were being
discovered and drawing them.
Okay? And he says in his
introduction that his goal
at Pompeii was "to
copy as faithfully
as possible ancient paintings
and to reproduce the original
with the accuracy
that science demands".
So he's responsible not
only for this set of, well,
you have two volumes here
but there is a third one,
but he also published many other
things, several other volumes.
And he is an extraordinary
character in many ways.
He was befriended by
Goethe in 1829 and, in fact,
when Zahn returned to Berlin
for this break in between,
he goes to Goethe and Goethe
immediately befriends him
and he spends weeks at a time
with Goethe and gets introduced
to all kinds of important
people like, you know,
the future King of Prussia.
And he is also extremely
important
because he is a major
figure in the development
of color lithography, which
I had no idea until recently.
I mean, this is all a
whole new world to me.
I moved to the 19th century,
little did I know how big
that move was going
to be, right?
And so he really used the
publication of these volumes
to push forward the
technology of lithography
and chromolithography
and apparently you can,
now I'm not trained to see
this so I can't point this out
and I'm sorry for that,
but apparently you can see
him develop the technology
from volume to volume to
volume, which is fascinating.
This was also a massive
effort and expense.
I read that it turns
out that Gerheimer,
who was a pretty well known,
large publisher in Berlin,
when he agreed to
publish Volume One,
this wasn't originally
conceived as a three-volume set,
it was just going
to be one volume,
when he originally agreed
to publish Volume One he
withheld the payment from Zahn
until he could see that it was a
financially successful endeavor.
And so once he saw that people
were buying these he paid Zahn
and eventually Zahn came
back and did Volume Two
and then Volume Three.
But we have some descriptions
by Zahn himself, which we know
about because Goethe includes
them in a review he does
of Zahn's Volume One, in
which Zahn talks about setting
up the lithography workshop
because this didn't exist.
And talking about 20 printers
and four to five artists
and it was incredible.
Now, there are some
other interesting things
that I just want to point
out but I am going to wrap it
up so I don't keep people
too long and I can try
to answer questions, and that is
this is only a connection I made
just recently so Zahn talks
about being most proud
of some specific plates in each
of the volumes that he's done
in terms of the challenge
that it was to produce them
and get the color just right and
things, and this is one of them.
This is plate 99
from Volume One.
And it turns out that
that's blue, right?
Because we have blue in our room
and everybody is always
saying 'oh it's American blue,
you know, Brumidi just
Americanized the background',
he took the black, right,
he took away the black Pompeiian
background and he made it blue.
And we actually have
a water color study
in which he also tried
out a red background.
But I never, I mean, I was
always thinking it's just sort
of American blue
background, right?
Well now, I'm pretty convinced
that he picked this blue
up from actual Pompeiian wall
paintings that he had seen.
And there's a whole debate
actually about this plate
that I'm currently
reading about,
because we not only have
Zahn's depiction of it
but have a 19th century
wash of it
and the blues are
slightly different
and the painted one is much
closer to our blue in the room.
So it's just fascinating
to look at that.
But anyway, so that's one thing.
Another thing that I'm
looking into is I wonder
if Brumidi actually
knew Wilhelm Zahn.
If you look at their
lives, so firs to fall,
they're both artists, right?
And there are areas
that are listed in red
where they overlap, right?
And so Zahn is known
to have stopped in Rome
for a bit before he
went down to Pompeii.
He came from Paris, stopped
in Rome, and went to Pompeii.
And so I'm in touch
with a former U.S. Capitol
Historical Society fellow
who has worked before in
the archives of the Academy
of de San Luca, the
famous art school
where Brumidi was trained,
and would know this, you know,
is this something that
might be recorded.
My question is, if you were
an artist and you hit Rome,
would you stop by this
famous art school?
I mean, I think you
would, right?
And so they could've
met maybe there,
certainly Brumidi would've
gone down to the Bay of Naples,
Zahn was hanging out
there with, you know,
admittedly other artists.
But still, I want to see if
that's a rabbit hole I would
like to do go down to see
if I can find some way
that they are connected,
if they are connected
or knew one another
or met one another.
So that's one idea.
The other thing that I need to
do some more work on is I would
like to see if I can
understand the circumstances
under which the Library of
Congress acquired those volumes.
So it turns out, right,
that there are notes
from the Committee of the
Library or the Committee
for the Library that are
in the National Archives.
Oh boy, anybody got
any leads over there?
But you can read the discussions
about acquisitions and what
to spend your money on and so
that I also want to follow up on
because I'm fascinated
by how they thought
to acquire these volumes.
And I've been looking
at the catalogues
and I'm still doing this to see.
So, in 1849, we did own
Gell, the British guy.
We owned [inaudible], a
different Italian guy,
and we owned this sort of
catalogue of the Bourbon Museum,
but we did not own the French
volume by Francois Masois.
We did not own another
German volume
of Pompeiian wall paintings
by this guy named [inaudible]
and the Niccolini brothers
hadn't published their thing
yet in 1849.
But I might look to see if
we purchased that in 1854
or shortly thereafter
when it came out,
whether, you know, they.
But the question is, why
did they pick these volumes
as opposed to Francois Masois,
as opposed to somebody else?
It's interesting so that's
another thing that I want
to look into and the last thing,
of course, is I have a lot
to learn about color
lithography,
which is very complicated
[laughter].
And it will be interesting
to see what we can then learn
from the samples
that we have here,
these copies that we have here.
I have done a little bit
of sleuthing using OCLC
and I can see 26 entries, 26
other volumes around the world.
So the other interesting
thing would be to know more
about how many of
these were printed,
how rare is this,
things like that.
So, anyway, I thank
you all for listening
and I really enjoyed figuring
out how we went from sort of,
you know, discovering Pompeii
in 1826 to publishing it in 1829
in Germany, in Berlin, to
painting it in adapted form
on the walls of the
U.S. Capitol Building.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Elise Friedland: [inaudible].
>> Michael North: Yes, please.
>> Elise Friedland: Hi.
>> Speaker 4: Hi.
What an amazing research
project [inaudible]
of investigation [inaudible],
just a stupendous job.
>> Elise Friedland: Thank you.
>> Speaker 4: I am very curious
to know, I know that the Brumidi
in the dome of the Capitol is
of one fresco painted
on wet fresco.
Were these paintings also
painted on wet plaster?
>> Elise Friedland: I have my
backup right here [laughter].
>> Speaker 5: No, no,
they're not true fresco.
Not the wall paintings,
not the maenads.
The ceiling is a temperate.
Nothing actually in that room
is true fresco, actually.
Well no, that's not true.
They've been scratched out
but the naval scenes
would've been true fresco.
>> Elise Friedland: That's a
whole sort of drama on the side
that didn't really
relate so I just left it.
There was an artist who
got asked, commissioned
to paint these and they
weren't happy with them
and he was disgruntled because
he wasn't getting paid enough
and he scratched
out his paintings
in those architectural.
But we have his names
scratched in, he was angry
so his name is scratched
in deeply into the plaster.
>> Speaker 4: But those
panels were actually painted
in one fresco whereas the rest
of the room was painted
on dry walls?
>> Elise Friedland: Mmhmm.
>> Speaker 4: Interesting.
>> Elise Friedland: And with
different kinds of, yeah,
with different kinds of paint.
Isn't there some oil?
>> Speaker 5: Well, there
were different artists
that worked with Brumidi.
>> Elise Friedland:
Brumidi, right.
I mean, he had a cast of
people working with him
because he covered an
incredible amount of territory
in the Capitol Building.
>> Speaker 4: Thank you.
>> Elise Friedland: I see a
question back there then I'm
going to come back to you.
>> Speaker 6: You might've
said this but I [inaudible].
So it went from these
frescos in Pompeii [inaudible]
and then was that, the line
goes Pompeii to Zahn to Brumidi
or did it go to Meigs?
Did Meigs get ivolved, did
Meigs point Brumidi to Zahn
or the other way around?
Or is that the crux
of the problem?
>> Elise Friedland:
That's a great question.
>> Speaker 5: Well, I mean,
Meigs clearly did point Brumidi
to a lot of sources so, I mean,
I think they had a mutual
admiration society going there
and I think they really, you
know, Meigs really was a conduit
to helping Brumidi gather this
information and access it.
But it's hard to
know the concept
if it really came
from, I don't know.
I mean, I felt like your theory
of perhaps they did
know each other-
>> Elise Friedland: Yeah.
>> Speaker 5: in Rome and, I
mean, every artist is looking
for images, that's what,
you know, artist do today
but they go online
instead of, you know,
looking for a folio print.
So I think that it
is hard to know,
it may be that Brumidi
had this idea
and then Meigs just
encouraged him.
I don't know the origin
of, I don't believe
that Meigs originated the
idea for this Pompeiian style.
But it's a good question.
>> Elise Friedland: Well
here is something that I did,
and I didn't think to put
an image of this in here.
Here's something that I did also
do in the Library of Congress.
There was another proposal
drawn up for this room
by another artist
named James Leslie.
And we have that in the Prints
and Photographs Division
in the Madison Building.
And they found them and
they uncovered them for me
and it was, I made a scene
because they uncovered
these and I was like, "Oh!
Those are horrible!"
They're not Pompeiian at all.
It's like a [inaudible]
artist trying to do Pompeii.
It was not at all right, okay?
And it's clear to me that
Meigs, who had the choice
of Brumidi's proposed thing,
the drawing, and James Leslie,
was discerning enough to
know this is Pompeiian style,
that is a [inaudible]
artist trying to look like.
I mean, so he had the proper
positions of the walls and,
but then he had these kind
of hokey subjects in there.
I mean, like little
coral, things of coral,
something that we don't have
that in the ancient world.
It just was all wrong.
And so in that degree I know
that Meigs was clearly
discerning and we know a lot
about Meigs as a patron and
the fact that Meigs, you know,
used the library in
New York extensively
and clearly was using
the Library
of Congress extensively
and was very learned.
And that's another path, I have
a lot of other rabbit holes
but I really want to look at
the curriculum of West Point
when Meigs went to school
there because I want to see
where he got this direct
link to the ancient world,
where he got that knowledge.
And we also have
another quote from him.
I sort of put some extra slides
in here, hang on one second.
That's it.
You know, there was, this
was, to decorate a room
in Pompeiian style was all
the rage in this period,
and particularly in palaces
as far north as Oslo.
So this wasn't just in, you
know, France and Italy and Spain
but I can show you in Oslo
and I've also been reading an
article recently by a scholar,
a colleague of mind who does
usually Roman wall painting
but Ludwig of Bavaria
who actually had the
interior decoration
of this palace he built modeled
directly from Wilhelm Zahn,
built the first reconstruction
of a Pompeiian house,
you know, outside of Italy.
So one of his castles is the
Pompeianum in a southern area
of Bavaria and he was basing it
directly on images from here.
So Meigs says in one of
his diaries that I want
to build a palace
for the people.
So his goal was to decorate the
U.S. Capitol Building the way,
you know, royalty were
decorating their palaces
throughout Europe.
So my question is
how does he now that?
How does he know that?
Because at this point
in his life he had not
been to Europe yet.
Yes ma'am?
>> Speaker 7: I think it was
essentially, I was trying
to figure out how did Brumidi
know about these [inaudible]
and that's essentially what
you just struggled to answer.
>> Elise Friedland:
Yeah, and I just hope
that this colleague
[inaudible], I did hear from him
but it was a 'I'm
opening a big exhibition,
I'll get back to you'.
But I really hope
that he can help me
because I just don't know
enough about the culture
and how things worked in the mid
or early 19th century
in Rome or in Europe.
But it seems to be me
that if you're coming
from the Casell Academy and
you're going to Paris, you know,
Paris to study with this
neoclassical painter,
that when you go to Rome
you're going to know
where the academy is
where Canova is the teacher
and things like that.
So it seems to me
that he would've had
to have had a connection.
I mean, he would've known this
academy and stopped there.
But I don't know.
I'm going to ask [inaudible]
who wrote a giant dissertation
on the Italian Revolution
and its impact
on the artist community of Rome.
So he's going to have a
handle on this for me.
>> Speaker 5: You know,
this other question though
about the Meigs and the Pompeii
connection, thinking back
that there was this competition,
if both artists were informed
or trying to approximate
a Pompeiian style then
that really would mean
that Meigs was driving
that because he would've
created the parameters
and this was Naval Affairs.
>> Elise Friedland: Right.
>> Speaker 5: So Brumidi,
knowing the source, really,
I think, sort of had
the ace in the hole
because he was going
back to these, you know,
think about this, you
know, house of the.
>> Elise Friedland:
The House of the Ship,
the casa del [inaudible] yeah.
>> Speaker 5: Yes.
I mean, that was the
perfect source [inaudible].
>> Elise Friedland:
Isn't that cute, yeah.
Now, mind you, he didn't,
that was the only thing
from the house of the ship that
he took that floating maiden
and the columns, and
the sort of design.
>> Speaker 5: Yep, that's
the key decorations.
>> Elise Friedland: Right.
But the other figures that I
showed you come from all over
and some we don't even have
their original context anymore,
they just got cut out of their
walls and he saw them in the.
He said, Zahn says,
Archeological Museum
in Naples, you know, sorry.
>> Speaker 5: Because the
competition sketches are just
for those logs.
>> Elise Friedland:
Right, right.
That's a good point.
>> Speaker 7: What's the
dates for the proposals?
I'm curious, for
the other proposals
that Leslie put [inaudible].
>> Elise Friedland: I don't
think there's a, well,
we got to just pdf it; I've
just got to search the PDF.
It's 54.
>> Speaker 5: Perhaps
[inaudible].
It took that many,
I'm trying to, no.
Not, I'm not sure actually.
I'd have to check.
>> Elise Friedland:
I think its 54-55
but it's in his diary because.
So, this is just
full disclosure.
The yucky thing that I saw,
it's not yucky but you know,
the thing that's not right
that I saw by James Leslie, is,
was purchased by the
Library of Congress.
And I was like how did
you know to purchase that
and how did you know that
this was a drying submitted
for this contest,
if you will or this.
>> Speaker 5: Competition.
>> Elise Friedland: Competition.
And it seems that I had a
hard time getting anybody
to reconstruct that but what
I do know is I've talked
with Barbara Walonin, the
former Curator of the Capitol,
and she is the one who said,
"Look, this says James Leslie,
we have James Leslie and we
have this entry in Meigs' diary
in which he describes, I
looked at this and it's,
he's not appropriate
for the room.
He's more of a decorative
painter."
This is what Meigs says, "He's
more of a decorative painter
and I'll hire him
to do other things."
And he does do other things in
the Capitol Building very well
but he says he's not for
the design of this floor.
So, I can get you that, I
just have to search my pdf
of the transcribed [inaudible].
>> Speaker 7: I was just curious
the trajectory and how long
between the [inaudible].
>> Elise Friedland: I think
it was 54 or 55, I really do.
>> Speaker 7: So not long.
>> Elise Friedland: Not long.
Yes?
>> Speaker 8: Quick question.
Brumidi is painting
in oil, is he not?
>> Elise Friedland:
Ooh, not always.
>> Speaker 5: Well he's painting
a lot of different media.
In this room it is
oil on plaster.
>> Speaker 8: Okay, fine.
And.
>> Speaker 5: Oil and casing
I think, it's a mixture.
>> Speaker 8: Okay, thank you.
And one of the questions
about books in the Library
of Congress is oh, did he
have borrowing privileges?
[inaudible].
>> Speaker 4: No.
>> Elise Friedland: No, l
[ Cross Talk ]
>> Speaker 5: Well that
would've been Meigs.
>> Elise Friedland: Yes.
>> Speaker 5: I mean,
Meigs would have.
>> Elise Friedland: Well, and
I also started this, right,
because Cheryl gave me the
log, the checkout registry
and that was interesting too
because I said to the guys
as they handed me this,
"Can I look at this?
Is this legal?"
Right? Because I can't
go into the Library today
and say what does this
student of mine, you know,
what does she have checked
out from Gellman, right?
But they said hmm,
that's a good question.
But you know, these
are from 1855
so you're okay, take
it [laughter].
And I started reading through
it but but it's hard to read
because it's different
[inaudible].
>> Speaker 8: Sure.
>> Elise Friedland: And also,
it was, I didn't see anything
like this and I decided that's
another rabbit hole to go back
to for sure but we do have
some letters in the files
in the Office of the Curator
of the Capitol that talk
about certain senators checking
out books on behalf of Brumidi.
So Brumidi had a couple
of senatorial friends
who would check these out
but Brumidi himself had
no borrowing privileges.
>> Speaker 8: So the
real question behind
that is would he
have had Zahn next
to him while he was
doing his art?
>>Elise Friedland: So
now we have to ask about,
and that's another thing I was
talking with John Cole about
but I have to do more reading
and understand but maybe one
of you guys from the
LOC can answer this.
I mean, what was the
reading room like
and at this point we are
still in the Capitol Building.
Could he have taken one of
these volumes down the hall
to his room where
he was working?
Didn't he have a room in
the Capitol, a studio-ish?
>> Speaker 5: I don't know that
Brumidi had his own studio.
I guess he had a place where he
could sort of keep his stuff.
Like the sculptors
had real studios.
>> Elise Friedland: Uh huh.
>> Speaker 5: But since his work
was all murals, but yes, I mean,
he had a place for his stuff.
>> Elise Friedland: Could
he have taken these down?
>> Speaker 9: There were
large tables kind of running
in the center of the room
and I think these
were probably shelved,
to help answer your question,
these were probably shelved
as folio and not in the regular
because architecture gets
wiped out in the fire.
>> Elise Friedland: Right.
>> Speaker 9: But
the folios don't
and it may have been
saved by size.
So, but I think,
given the size of it,
I would guess he'd
be more inclined
to work there just
by the nature of.
>> Elise Friedland: And can an
artist bring his water colors?
>> Speaker 9: Well
that's another question.
If he's.
>> Elise Friedland: Into
your library at that point?
>>Speaker 9: Well, their library
library isn't quite the same
as my library.
[ Laughter ]
But if you want a contemporary
answer to that, no way.
>> Elise Friedland:
No, I got that.
>> Speaker 9: Yeah.
Maybe, I'm sure there must've
been some kind of, I'm not sure.
I would imagine it wouldn't be
that difficult to make that kind
of arrangement if need be.
>> Michael North: And
what about [inaudible]?
>> Elise Friedland: Okay,
so this is something.
I think hanging out with
Michael and these books
because every time I
come here, Michelle,
that second one is open for
you and I to look at afterwards
and Michael just
happened to open it here.
I'm like, "Oh my God,
there are the heads!"
But there are the heads.
But, we, I came in and I
said, "Michael, the books,
I want to see plate 99."
Which is way back here but,
you know, this blue thing
that I was talking about,
because I wanted to see
if I could, Zahn talks about
being very proud of this
in particular because, I don't
understand this well enough
because I don't do
color lithography
because it doesn't occur in
the Roman world but you had
to print it and then he had
to fill in some colors by hand
and I was interested to see
could I see that, you know,
but I'm not trained
enough to see that.
So I said, "Can I see plate 99?"
So Michael opens it and
he's like, where's plate 99.
It's missing.
It's cut out.
>> Speaker 5: Well, now we know
exactly what he did [laughter].
>> Elise Friedland: Well,
except that he, wait, it's more,
at first we were like,
oh my God, Brumidi!
But these seem to
have, again, Cheryl,
these seem to have been
bound, like it's in my notes,
like 1910 or something.
>> Speaker 9: They had
been re-bound, yeah.
>> Elise Friedland:
Okay so re-bound.
>> Speaker 9: Possibly re-bound
or may have been
re-bound [inaudible].
I would check the
inventory of the Capitol.
>> Elise Friedland: Right.
Well, that's what
I said to Michael.
I said, "I've got to
talk to Michelle and find
out what's in the archives.
>> Speaker 9: Yeah,
I mean framed
on some senator's
office wall [laughter].
>> Speaker 10: With
an LOC stamp.
>> Speaker 9: With an LOC stamp.
[ Laughter ]
And they'll get a letter from
us any day now [laughter].
>> Elise Friedland:
Oops, I just got myself
in trouble on multiple fronts.
But anyway, that was a pretty
cool discovery we just made
standing here.
>> Speaker 11: So, how
would he have done it?
Are you suggesting he would
have the book there in the room
and designed it on the wall?
He would've sketched
it on the wall
or he would've sketched
it down in advance?
>> Elise Friedland: We
know that he had cartoons
that he sketched out in advance.
So we have this one watercolor
that is in the Archives
of the Architect of the Capitol,
that was his proposal to Meigs.
But what's really lovely,
and then he would make larger
cartoons and transfer them
to the wall and blah,
blah, blah, right?
But what's really interesting
about this is that he,
in a sense, is mirroring
what Zahn used to do.
So one of the things that I
read about that's so important
about Zahn's books is that Zahn
was standing there in front
of these walls, right?
And so what he would do was
put tracing paper on there and,
you know, take down the design.
I'm going, don't look,
you'll get dizzy.
I'm going back to my whole wall.
Okay, here.
And then he could
transfer that to the stones
to create these lithographs,
right?
So that was the allure
of lithography, right?
It took out an intermediary step
going to a copper plate, right,
that would therefore make the
resulting print less direct,
less of an exact
copy if you will.
This is going to get really
complicated because you're going
to get into the whole issue
of copies and copying,
which is a total nightmare.
I know enough about
that from Roman copies
of Greek originals, right?
so this is going to get dicey
because any time you
start is this a copy,
how accurate is Zahn, blah,
blah, blah, well, you know,
some of these wall paintings
we don't have anymore
so how do we know?
Some of them we do.
In any event, that's
kind of neat
because that's how
Zahn was creating these
and that was the
lure of lithography
and that's why he wanted to
use this medium and he worked
so hard to push the medium
to create these volumes.
>> Speaker 5: So
he's the first one
to really record color
in that way, I guess.
>> Elise Friedland:
He certainly, yes.
>> Speaker 5: Paintings that
were water colors probably.
>> Elise Friedland: Yes.
I'm going to be careful.
Like, come back to me
in like, after the end
of the summer once I've waded
through several more German
articles on this topic
and also I don't know
enough about print making.
My last job was in a Department
of Art and Art History
and my office was across
from the print studio
and I was friends
with that professor
but I did not pay enough
attention [laughter].
And she is now at
the University,
I was telling Michael, she
is now at the University
of Richmond, that's right there.
I'm calling Ms. Tonya
[inaudible] and I'm going
to say, "Can I come
for the weekend
and can you teach me
all about lithography."
Because, you know,
what do I know?
Anyway, okay.
>> Speaker 12: So
were Zahn's volumes
in the Academy de
San Luca [inaudible]?
>> Elise Frieldand: That's good.
Hopefully [inaudible] will
reply to my email, yes.
That's a great question.
I mean, I don't know.
Yeah. There is something
at National Gallery
that I just realized
that's some sort of study
of the holdings,
what does that mean?
Does that mean art or
does that mean library
of the Academy de San Luca
and that's another trail.
This is a lot of
stuff to follow up on.
Yeah, I don't know.
Okay?
>> Speaker 8: Sorry, one more.
>> Elise Friedland: Okay.
>> Speaker 8: So the color.
>> Elise Friedland: Yes.
>> Speaker 8: Zahn's doing
an overlay and a tracing.
>> Elise Friedland: Mmhmm.
>> Speaker 8: When does
he put the color on?
>> Elise Friedland: He
describes the color.
So part of the catalogue
entries that are
so cute is that he describes.
He'll say the wings were
yellow and the this was red
and the background was that.
>> Speaker 8: Red?
>> Elise Friedland: I
know, I know, I know.
I know it's not very exact.
I know.
>> Speaker 8: And so therefore
when he recreated his work
in Berlin he decided
what blue would be blue
because it's a gorgeous
blue and it's a unique blue.
>> Elise Friedland: Mmhmm.
Yeah I know.
I know. I know.
Mmhmm.
>> Speaker 8: Cool.
>> Elise Friedland: And, by
the way, there's all sorts
of important new research
that, and this is not
to effect Zahn although it's
interesting they noticed this,
they recognized this.
There's all sorts of new
research about the effects
of the pyroclastic flow
on the colored walls
in Pompeiian wall painting
and how some yellows turn
red, so Pompeiian red-
>> Speaker 8: Oh.
>> Elise Friedland:
might be, oops, you know?
And it is interesting that
something I was reading said
that some of these
artists noticed some
of this, like walls were-
>> Speaker 5: Transitioning.
>> Elise Friedland:
transitioning.
That's a good way
to describe it.
Like, part of the wall
was still yellow, ochre,
and part of it, you know.
Anyway, so, right.
It's complicated but anyway.
Okay.
>> Michael North:
Well, thank you Elise.
>> Elise Friedland: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Speaker 1: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.